I want to quickly go to Fox's Brian Yus
uh we'll get back to the legal pan in a
moment who's outside the jail where
Trump is inside right now our political
panel also standing by Brian what was
the
scene Laura good evening well it was a
spectacle as you had said earlier in the
show really let me give you an idea of
how the security is out here this is a
hard lockdown according to the Fulton
County Sheriff to your left over here
you can see the line of sheriff deputies
as well as the roads that are blocked
here on Jefferson Street this is right
in front of the entrance where we just
saw the motorcade coming in now this
area has been locked down for at least
the last couple of hours on the other
side of the jail there are about 150 or
so Trump supporters and protesters that
have been out here uh rallying all day
and if we actually keep turning the
camera you can see they even have
dumpster trucks here blocking the way
this is all part of the security
obviously when you have an unprecedented
event as a former president that is now
currently being booked inside of that
jail you can also see tons of press that
have been barricaded out here on
Jefferson street from what we understand
what's happening right now inside if
Cappy can show the jail we uh can only
show you from where we are right now but
you know Patrick lebot who is the
sheriff here says that they're going to
go through normal protocol as any
criminal defendant we'll see if that
ends up happening with negotiations with
the Secret Service but normal protocol
means he'll have to go through the
magnetometers he'll be fingerprinted
after he surrenders and he'll also yes
we anticipate take a mug shot and we
know that that mug shot will be made
available fairly quickly because they've
done this before 11 of the last uh well
11 of the 18 codefendants of the former
president have turned themselves in and
their mug shots have been released in
including former white house chief of
staff Mark Meadows who turned himself in
today and was released on a $100,000
bond that mug shot will be made
available for the public for everyone to
see it even includes the weight of the
defendant so that'll give you an idea as
to uh just how much information we'll
get obviously this is the fourth time
that the former president has gone
through something like this his fourth
criminal case but this is the first time
that he's had to uh well go in and be
booked like this and have a mug shot
taken it'll be the first time he'll also
have to pay a bond to be released you'll
have to pay a $200,000 bond to be
released from that Fulton County Jail I
think also lur I want people to
understand is that when they're looking
at this jail right now this is not a
normal jail this is a notorious jail
that is under a doj investigation for
its heinous conditions and excessive
violence Laura Brian thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else